this morning Britain is warned a warning
Iran of what it describes as serious
consequences if Iran does not release a
British flag tanker that it seized in
the Persian Gulf Iran claims the tanker
collided with an Iranian fishing boat in
the Strait of Hormuz this morning
Germany and France called on Iran to
release that tanker at the White House
Friday President Trump commented on the
increasing tension in that strategic oil
shipping route so we're going to be
speaking with the UK and this only goes
to show what I'm saying about Iran
trouble nothing but trouble David Martin
is with the top US military commander
for the Middle East the man in charge of
handling this latest crisis in the
Persian Gulf David spoke with him this
morning we were traveling with general
Frank McKenzie in Afghanistan when those
two British tankers were seized
he told CBS News exactly what happened
the first ship was flying a British flag
as it passed through the Strait of
Hormuz at the mouth of the Persian Gulf
she was fired upon subsequently boarded
taken under Iranian custody and it's now
deep in Iranian territorial waters the
second British tanker was flying a
Liberian flag the Iranian boarded her we
believe they searched for British
persons found none and then eventually
allowed her to continue her voyage three
hours later an American flag cargo ship
the Maersk Chicago went through the
Strait with what Mackenzie called iron
overhead meaning f-18 jet fighters
flying air cover the Iranians left it
alone the u.s. now has destroyers
stationed at either end of the strait
those destroyers have orders to
intervene if they see
another ship hijacking they would only
do so in the case of a us-flagged vessel
coming under attack president Trump has
made it clear he does not want a war
with Iran and general McKenzie told CBS
News the US military is determined not
to overreact CBS this morning Saturday
David Martin and Kabul Afghanistan